all right well the historic Victory
Parade set for tomorrow evening as we've
been telling you this trip will be shut
down in both directions of course from
Flamingo to Tropicana starting at 4 30.
a busy Saturday but with hundreds of
thousands of fans anticipated to show up
some are concerned they physically won't
be able to join it is our reporter Ryan
Matthew joining us live near Toshiba
Plaza with this dilemma today Ryan
so we all saw the video from Tuesday 11
500 people overtook Toshiba Plaza during
the winning game it didn't leave a lot
of room to move around let alone drive a
Mobility Scooter through it so some fans
with some certain limitations are
concerned about missing this historic
event because they simply can't get
around it
but you're not a drinker not anymore huh
Danny Cook has the golden knights
whiskey I've got jackets hats everything
all the vgk swag I've got neuropathy for
one and I've got congestive heart
failure and a mix of medical
complications coming your way that
balance him to an electric scooter when
he goes out I can only walk
so far and then basically I've got to
sit down and stop
he's been a fan since the beginning and
with the historic Stanley Cup win he
wants to prove that by going to the
golden knights parade but I can't can't
take a chance if somebody hit me and
knocking me down because I'm not stable
[Applause]
the crowd just inside the plaza Tuesday
evening the crowd Saturday night
expected to multiply according to the
team's owner we've told the city and the
county it's a hundred thousand but
according to Metro Police we're going to
guess in a New Year's Eve crowd that
crowd over 400 000 across the entire
Strip This parade just a single mile
from Flamingo to Tropicana and while the
Regional Transportation Commission tries
to ease traffic pains with round-trip
rides from six different locations it'll
be busy Metro confirms medically
necessary Vehicles will be allowed but
says accommodations for differently
abled Spectators are quote still being
worked out it's because we have a
disability doesn't mean we shouldn't be
able to
participate
now there's not going to be any
prohibition on canes or walkers but when
we asked Clark County and the Vegas
golden knights about some of these
proposed accommodations we did not hear
back for everybody else who is going to
the event important to note this is
probably the largest size bag you're
allowed to bring anything beyond 12 by 6
by 12 inches will not be allowed
reporting live outside Toshiba Plaza
Ryan Matthey a news now